en el vídeo anterior usamos la teoría
cpr para moléculas con 5 nubes
electrónicas en este vídeo haremos otros
dos ejercicios
digamos que queremos encontrar la
geometría del tri fluoruro de cloro
entonces primero hay que dibujar la
estructura de puntos de louis y para eso
hay que calcular los electrones de
valencia el cloro se encuentra en el
grupo 7 de la tabla periódica así que
tiene 7 electrones de valencia y el
flúor también se encuentra en el grupo 7
pero como tenemos tres átomos de flúor 7
por 3 es igual a 21 más 7 tenemos 28
electrones de valencia en total ahora el
cloro será el átomo central porque no
están electro negativo como el flúor y
está unido a 3 átomos de flúor
entonces ya colocamos 246 electrones de
valencia y 28 menos 6 nos faltan 22
electrones de valencia por colocar
podemos empezar a colocarlos en nuestros
átomos terminales los átomos de flúor
como el flúor cumple con la regla del
octeto y cada uno ya tenía 2 electrones
a su alrededor sólo necesita 6
electrones más si agregamos 6 electrones
de valencia a 3 átomos de flúor entonces
6 por 3 es igual a 18 y 22 menos 18 aún
nos quedan 4 electrones de valencia por
colocar y recuerden que cuando tenemos
electrones sobrantes los podemos colocar
en el átomo central así que tenemos dos
pares de electrones libres en nuestro
cloro ya colocamos todos los electrones
de valencia
observen que el cloro excede su octeto
pero no hay problema porque se encuentra
en el tercer periodo de la tabla
periódica y si analizamos la carga
formal encontrarán que el cloro tiene
una carga formal igual a cero entonces
esta es nuestra estructura de puntos de
louis en el segundo paso necesitamos
contar el número de nubes electrónicas
que rodean al átomo central recordemos
que las nubes electrónicas son regiones
de densidad electrónica que pueden ser
tanto enlaces como pares de electrones
libres entonces este enlace es una nube
electrónica por acá tenemos otra aquí
tenemos otra y los pares de electrones
libres también se consideran nubes
electrónicas así que esta es una nube
electrónica
aquí tenemos otra entonces tenemos 5
nubes electrónicas en total rodeando a
nuestro átomo central ahora en el paso 3
podemos predecir la geometría de esas
nubes electrónicas en el vídeo anterior
explicamos cómo la teoría de sfr nos
ayuda a entender que sin con nubes
electrónicas adoptan una geometría y
pirámide trigon al así que en este caso
las nubes electrónicas tendrán la misma
geometría pero aquí la diferencia son
los pares de electrones libres en donde
los ponemos bueno como los pares de
electrones libres ocupan más espacio que
los electrones que forman enlaces
repelen un poco más en el vídeo anterior
hablamos con detalle de que lo ideal es
poner a los electrones libres en una
posición ecuatorial para minimizar la
repulsión entre los electrones entonces
hagan
lo mismo tenemos nuestro átomo de cloro
en el centro y después tenemos un par de
electrones libres en esta posición
ecuatorial también tenemos otro par de
ecuatorial y por lo tanto tenemos un
átomo de flúor en la última posición
ecuatorial y los dos átomos de flúor que
nos faltan los pondremos en posición
axial uno hacia arriba y uno hacia abajo
entonces al poner los pares de
electrones libres en las posiciones
ecuatoriales minimizamos la repulsión
esta es nuestra estructura
hay que ignorar cualquier parte
electrones libres alrededor del átomo
central para predecir la geometría de la
molécula entonces si ignoramos los pares
de electrones libres voy a redibujar la
molécula tenemos dos átomos de flúor en
posición axial y tenemos un átomo de
flúor en posición ecuatorial a 90 grados
de los átomos axiales observen que aquí
los átomos están alineados y este flúor
se encuentra a 90 grados es una
geometría en forma de t
esta es la geometría en forma de t y en
términos del ángulo de enlace aquí
tenemos un ángulo de 90 grados y por acá
tenemos un ángulo de 180 grados
estos son los ángulos de enlace ideales
en la geometría en forma de t
muy bien hagamos otro ejemplo ahora
tenemos el ión trillo duro y 3 y una
carga negativa primero vamos a dibujar
la estructura de puntos de lewis para
eso sabemos que el yodo se encuentra en
el grupo 7 de la tabla periódica y como
tenemos tres átomos 7 por 3 es igual a
21 electrones de valencia pero como
tenemos una carga negativa hay que
agregar un electrón 21 más uno es igual
a 22 electrones de valencia en total que
colocaremos en nuestra estructura
entonces tenemos tres átomos de yodo ya
colocamos cuatro electrones de valencia
aquí tenemos dos y dos y 22 menos cuatro
nos faltan 18 electrones de valencia por
colocar que podemos empezar a colocar en
nuestros átomos terminales
recuerden que el yodo puede cumplir con
la regla del octeto así que agregamos 6
electrones más a cada átomo de yodo
terminal ya colocamos otros 12
electrones de valencia y 18 menos 12 aún
nos quedan 6 electrones que podemos
colocar en nuestro átomo central así que
el yodo central tiene tres pares de
electrones libres y como esta molécula
es unión vamos a ponerlo entre corchetes
para señalar la carga negativa esta es
nuestra estructura ahora observen que el
yodo central excede su ocde pero no hay
problema por la posición que ocupa en la
tabla periódica y si calculamos la carga
formal obtendremos una carga negativa
entonces regresemos a los pasos
dibujamos la estructura de puntos de
louis ahora en el paso 2 hay que contar
el número de nubes electrónicas que
rodean al átomo central entonces vamos a
ver este enlace es una nube electrónica
al igual que este enlace y estos pares
de electrones libres también son nubes
electrónicas así que en total tenemos
sheen con nubes electrónicas para esta
estructura y la geometría que adoptan
sheen con nubes electrónicas esta
pirámide trigon al entonces tenemos a
nuestro átomo de yodo central y
recuerden que es recomendable poner los
pares de electrones libres en las
posiciones ecuatoriales para minimizar
la repulsión entre los electrones
entonces pongamos los pares de
electrones libres que rodean al átomo
central en las posiciones ecuatoriales
y después vamos a poner los dos átomos
de yodo en las posiciones axiales uno
hacia arriba y el otro hacia abajo así
es como se ve nuestro ión regresemos a
nuestros pasos ya hicimos el paso 3 pre
dijimos que la geometría de las nubes
electrónicas es mi pirámide tribunal
pero para predecir la geometría de en
este caso el guión hay que ignorar los
pares de electrones libres entonces si
ignoramos los pares de electrones libres
alrededor del átomo central observen que
nos queda una línea recta así que la
geometría de lyon es lineal
y como es lineal podemos predecir que el
ángulo de enlace esté aproximadamente
180 grados ya hicimos cuatro ejemplos de
cinco nubes electrónicas con diferentes
números de pares de electrones libres
alrededor del átomo central